MEGHAN DESAI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the
Project Volta session.
This was previously known as
the Android Power Performance
Primer.
If you can say that three
times, five times as fast, there
might be a prize
in it for you guys.
But this is the introduction
to Project Volta.
My name is Meghan.
I'm a product
manager on Android,
and I have here with me Matthew.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: I'm Matthew.
I work on Android Cloud.
MEGHAN DESAI: And we're here
to talk about Project Volta.
So we know that
today, battery life
is one of the biggest
complaints that users
have with Android
devices out there.
As we live in a world
that's more and more mobile,
it's really important
that we have
devices that last the
full day at least.
And I could not tell
you how many times
I've been in a situation where,
after a long day at work,
I'm trying to get a ride
home and I can't call
a ride because my phone
is out of battery.
So we're really passionate
about addressing this issue,
and that was the impetus
of Project Volta.
With Project Volta, we looked
across the platform, Android
platform, to see what
opportunities lie there
for improvement.
We wanted to figure
out what tools
and APIs we could build for
you guys to make it easier
for you to make your
applications more efficient
and also increase the
transparency about power
consumption for users.
So you saw some of
the features that
are more user facing at
the keynote from Dave.
This session is going
to focus specifically
on the tools and APIs that
we have built for you guys.
So let's dig a little bit
deeper into some of the analysis
that we did.
We started out
looking at a Nexus 5,
and we said, let's
establish a baseline.
We turned off
everything on there,
so it was in airplane
mode, screen off,
so completely in standby.
And that gives you something
like a month of battery life.
But of course, we don't
do this to our devices.
We actually use them throughout
the course of the day.
We put them on cellular.
We make calls.
We have Wi-Fi.
We have applications
that are syncing.
We are checking our
social networks.
We're playing games.
The screen is on.
Well, all of that adds
up, and the battery life
goes way, way down
to less than a day.
So that red line that
you're seeing there-- that's
where we saw the
opportunity, and we
wanted to dig even
deeper into there
and figure out what
can we do there.
So we decided to take
a more microscopic look
at what's happening.
And before I go into more, let
me talk about three active use
cases I'm going to talk
about as we do this analysis.
First, the application
processor being awake.
We know that when the
application processor's awake,
power is being consumed.
Next, the cellular
radio being awake,
and we're going to look
at what happens when that
is awake and is
doing its activity.
And then, finally, the
screen being awake.
That's one of the biggest
drawers of power on the device.
So we'll take a look
at each of these.
Again, first, let's establish
ourselves a baseline.
So what you're seeing here
is current draw over time.
So we basically hooked up
an amp meter to the device
to measure what's happening,
what kind of power
is being drawn by
the device over time.
So this baseline right here is
in standby-- that standby mode
I just described where the only
thing that is really active
is that the cellular radio is
in its standby state, where
it periodically checks
in with the cell tower.
And that's what these
little spikes are.
So this is our baseline.
Very little power
is being consumed.
Let's say you wanted
to turn the CPU on just
for a brief period of time.
This is what happens.
So we turn the
application processor on.
The processor turns on.
It checks to see if there's
any work to do or not.
And then it goes off because
there's nothing to do.
This was a no-op.
Well, just to do that, that
much power is consumed.
You can see that it's actually
on for a little over a second.
And what's happening is
that the processor has
to turn on, load all
these things into its RAM
and into its memory and
figure out what it needs to do
or if it doesn't do
anything, and then it
tears everything down.
So that's consuming power.
And you can think of the
area underneath that curve,
the integral-- that is the
power, the many amp-hours that
are being consumed.
Next, let's take a
look at what happens
when you want to send a
packet over the LTE radio.
So we decided to simulate
sending one packet over LTE,
and here's the shape we saw.
So it starts out in standby,
and then we see these spikes.
So the cellular
radio's coming up.
It sends the packet.
It receives this
acknowledgement.
But then you see all these
little spikes afterwards.
So first you see
a few big spikes--
that's when the
activity is happening.
Then afterwards you see this
long tail of little spikes.
But what's happening there is
that the radio decides that,
hey, I just sent this packet.
Maybe there's more work to do.
So I'm going to stay in
this in-between state.
I'm not completely in
standby, but I'm ready
just in case something comes up.
Well, that seems reasonable.
That makes a lot of sense.
But if this happens
a lot-- that that's
extra energy that
is spent-- then
the device is not actually
doing anything useful.
So we'll come back to that.
I think there's some
opportunity there.
Let's quickly take
a look at what
happens when the
screen turns on.
There's a big spike.
You would expect that
because the screen
is a huge, huge power consumer.
One of the biggest ones because
you had to turn on these LEDs
and paint the screen and do
the processing to figure out
what to actually
show on the screen.
So turning the screen
on for a second,
this is what we saw as a
curve for power consumption.
Cool.
So let's take a look at
this in a different way.
Let's compare that to
that baseline that we saw.
Let's assume that we wanted
to do one of these active use
cases for one second.
So we took the power that that
consumes and divided into it
the standby power to figure
out what are we trading off
when we keep the device
active for one second.
And it turns out
that we actually
trade off two
minutes of standby.
This is a rough number
across those three use cases.
Obviously, you're
going to be trading
off more if the screen
is on for one second.
But let's say it's two
minutes for the sake of this--
or roughly two minutes.
Do two minutes really matter?
That seems like a really
small amount of time.
Well, if it was just once,
just once this was happening,
then, yeah, it
doesn't really matter.
But let's take an example where
you have 50 apps on the device.
We have tons and tons
of apps on our devices.
They're syncing all the time.
We're using those
apps all the time.
Let's say you had
50 apps on a device,
and they were each keeping
the processor or the cell
radio or the screen on
for one second every hour,
each of them doing this.
Well, that amounts to 100
minutes of standby time
that you trade off every hour.
You do this for eight
hours, that's 800 minutes.
That's a lot of minutes.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: That's huge.
MEGHAN DESAI:
That's huge, right?
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Yeah.
MEGHAN DESAI: Yeah.
So why can't apps
just be lazier?
What if apps were just lazier?
MATTHEW WILLIAMS:
I'm not sure, Meghan.
That sounds kind of gimmicky.
Could you explain
this some more?
MEGHAN DESAI: Yeah,
sure, Matthew.
Let me introduce a concept
called "lazy first."
The idea here is that
if your application
can be lazy first,
then be lazy first.
The obvious way to do this?
Reduce the number of times that
you keep the device active.
That seems like a no-brainer,
but of course, that's
not doable all the time.
There's a lot of
legitimate times
when you need to be
connecting to the network
or keeping a wake lock.
So maybe you can coalesce
a lot of these activities.
If you have a lot of
network calls in succession,
you can group them
together into one call,
so you pay less of that overhead
that we just talked about.
Now, finally, you can defer it.
If you have content
that needs to be updated
to the application
every week, it
doesn't need to
happen right away.
It can happen.
You can defer it to maybe when
the phone is charged or plugged
in.
That's what I mean by
"lazy first," Matthew.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS:
OK, I mean, I guess
when you put it in that context,
this makes a lot of sense.
So on mobile, we
have these devices
which are constantly
transitioning states.
So it's a quite likely
scenario that you're
going to be in a
situation where it's
expensive to do certain
types of operations.
But if you can wait
for long enough--
and that's the key of the
matter, this waiting-- you're
most likely going to
get into a situation
where the environment is
much more cost effective.
So essentially, the thing
we'd like you to ask yourself
is, what is the
longest amount of time
that I'm willing to
do this type of thing?
And then you can schedule
this work based on that.
But this is kind of a big ask,
because the infrastructure
up until now just
hasn't really existed.
But that's changed
in L. So we've
built out a new
set of APIs, which
we're calling the
JobScheduler, which
make it really easy to specify
these types of constraints
that directly target
the types of work
that you're
interested in and then
provide a callback
for the system
to know when your application,
this logic, should be run.
So I'm talking
about jobs and work,
but what exactly do I mean?
For example, like a non
user-facing network call.
So this is a case where
the users interact
with the application and you
have some data to upload,
and they're not expecting
any sort of callback.
They're not expecting to
see any change in the UI.
So yeah, you could
upload this immediately,
but if the user isn't expecting
to see anything from this,
why not wait?
Why not defer this operation?
Another example that
we could think about
is any sort of CPU
intensive operation.
This is video processing.
This is database cleanup.
Again, non-user facing,
really easy to defer
if the infrastructure did exist.
So just another
example-- any sort
of job you want to
perform periodically,
like some sort of Cron job
or something that you'd
like to happen at some
point in time in the future.
So let's take a look
at a specific example.
Every 15 hours, perform some
database cleanup and maybe
upload some logs to my server.
So at this point, this probably
looks like a common situation
that a lot of you
have done and have
had to do on a regular basis.
And you're wondering, well,
why has the Android team gone
to all the trouble of
building out this brand
new API for something
that's been possible
since the inception of Android?
But then again, if
you've done this before,
you probably agree with me
that it's not that simple.
So in the first place,
you want something
to happen in about 15
hours, so you set up
an alarm with the Alarm Manager.
That's fine.
That's pretty simple
and well understood.
But the Alarm Manager doesn't
persist these operations.
So you're going to probably have
to write some stuff to storage.
And at this point, all
you're really interested in
is a wall-clock
time plus whatever
parameters you were interested
in in the first place
that you need to do this work.
But 15 hours passes.
The Alarm Manager sends
you your broadcast.
Your app wakes up, and it
tries to hit the network,
and there's no connectivity.
So at this point, you register
with the Connectivity Manager
to let you know when
connectivity comes back.
But we're on mobile,
and these environments
are constantly changing.
Your network could be flapping,
your server could be down,
or there could be all
sorts of failure scenarios.
So you go into a failure state.
You're doing your own back-off.
You set up some more alarms
in the Alarm Manager.
You have to track this failure.
You have to write all of these
parameters dealt into storage,
because you're using
the Alarm Manager,
and if the device reboots,
all that stuff will go away.
So it's really not that
simple, but let's take a look
at how we do this with
something like JobScheduler.
So again, you're
seeing here that we're
providing this
builder, which you
use to produce this
job-in-four objects,
and a job-in-four is
an exact encapsulation
of what it is that
you like to do.
So in the constructor,
your provide a job ID,
which is some integer that you
assign for the job yourself
which you use to differentiate
this job from other jobs
that you might schedule
against the system.
And then you give it
the service components.
And this is your service
that you subclass
that we provide where your
execution logic is housed,
and we'll talk about
that some more later.
In this case, we're asking
for any sort of network,
but if you know you have
a bunch of uploads to do
and you want an
unmetered network,
you can also ask for
that type of thing.
Then you set in the
timing constraints.
In this case, I want this
to periodically happen
every 15 hours.
And then you're asking that
the device be plugged in.
And that's it.
There you have it.
So we saw a bunch
of-- this example
has a lot of
interesting criteria.
But this kind of just
scratches the surface
of the types of things you
can do with the JobScheduler.
Let's look at some
of the other things.
Let's look at it all in total.
So the first thing that
we've introduced in L,
and this is brand new, is this
network activity awareness.
Now this is actually a
Connectivity Manager API
that we've integrated against.
So you can use this
in your applications
if you wanted to
do your own stuff.
But for our purposes-- and this
is getting back to that graph
you saw earlier that Meghan
showed-- that really long tail
where the network
was not quite idle
but wasn't quite active either.
So if we're aware that the
radio card is in that state,
we can piggyback
on that and take
advantage of that opportunity.
The next thing we're going
to introduce is Idle mode.
So this is, as it sounds
like, a period of time
for which the system has
determined that the phone is
not being used and is not
likely to be used anytime soon.
So just to take an
example, if you set up
a job that required Idle
mode and also charging,
this would probably be
executed sometime at night
when the user is
sleeping and the phone
is plugged into the wall
or on their bedside table
next to them.
And from a battery
perspective, you
can't do much better than that.
You can hammer the CPU.
You can do whatever you want.
The user isn't around to
see any of this stuff.
And when they wake up in the
morning, the battery's at 100%
because it was
plugged in all night.
We've also consolidated a bunch
of pre-existing functionality.
We saw this in the
previous example.
You can ask for tasks to run
while the device is charging.
And you can also specify
different types of network.
So these are the types
of powerful criteria
that you can specify, but let's
talk a bit about the features.
So as I mentioned,
the JobScheduler,
you don't have to worry
about persistence at all.
You can specify your
execution state.
You hand a bundle of
parameters to the system,
to the JobScheduler, and we
take care of that for you.
We hand that back to
you at execution time,
no matter how often a device may
have rebooted in the interim.
And then you can specify, on a
period job basis, your back-off
and retry criteria.
And I think this is particularly
powerful, because you
can say, for example, that
you want this back-off to be
linear-- whether you want
it to be exponential--
and you also specify the
initial back-off time.
So you can decide for
yourself how you want your job
to behave when it gets
into a failure state.
And finally, set up
these timing criteria.
You can [INAUDIBLE] once,
at one point in the future,
or just to reoccur periodically.
So because examples
are fun, let's
take a look at another one.
And this one is
going to look more
at the timing side of things
rather than the other one.
So again, we're using
some integer job
ID, which you've incremented
by one in this case,
because we used some
integer in the last example.
Same, this is providing end
point to the JobScheduler.
But here we're
seeing that I don't
want this to run until
five seconds has passed.
So only after five seconds will
this be eligible for execution.
And this is an
interesting setup.
In this case, we're
overriding with a deadline.
So were saying, in 15
minutes, come what may,
this task has to run.
So for example, you
think that if we
asked the network
but 15 minutes passed
and there wasn't a network
because the phone is
in airplane mode or there
just was nothing available,
you would be run anyways.
So this is a
guarantee for you guys
to know that your job will
occur by a certain point.
But bearing in mind that
if you set this deadline,
it's your responsibility
to check in your code
that the device is charging or
that the network is connected.
So that's an example.
And we've seen, so
far, how you build
these objects, a bunch
of different criteria,
and the functionality
you get and how
you hand them to
the JobScheduler.
Let's talk a bit about how
you execute your logic.
It is pretty simple.
The system, when it's
determined that your job is
eligible to run, will just call
onStartJob in your service.
And the service in this case
is a service that we provide,
so you don't have to worry
about any of the service life
cycle mechanisms or
anything like that.
You just override
onStartJob, bearing in mind
that this happens in the main
thread of the application.
So any RIFF that
you want to do, you
have to ofFbo it using any
of the numerous framework
components that let you
do concurrent programming.
You do your work, and you call
a job finished when you're done.
But we set up a
bunch of criteria
like, for example, charging.
And it might be the case
that you're doing your work
and the phone is unplugged.
So the facility for
that is that if this
happens and the criteria that
you set up are no longer valid,
the system will call
onStopJob to let you
know, hey, you need to wrap
up whatever you're doing
and stop doing your work.
So yeah, that's it.
I mean, I think it's
a really powerful API.
It's really simple to use.
You just hand a lot of the
complicated functionality
to scheduler, and you
worry about what's
important to you-- just
executing your logic.
But how do we actually
measure that we've
made some improvements?
MEGHAN DESAI: That's an
excellent question, Matthew.
We talked about all these
APIs and some of the issues
that we discovered earlier.
Well, you start investing
energy into building them,
and you want to be able to know
that you're making a difference
and you're actually
improving the battery life.
So one of the ways to do
this is to literally hook up
an amp meter to
the battery leaves.
That's pretty much
what we did when
we came up with
that chart earlier
that you saw-- those charts that
showed current draw over time.
This sounds pretty cool,
but we did this in a lab
with equipment.
It's probably not practical
for most of you out there.
So we've improved the
on-board battery stats.
These are the things
on device-- information
that's collected that's
relevant to the power
consumption on the device.
So let's talk about that.
This is the same
set of information
that is currently powering the
Battery Settings page, where
you can see which applications
or system components are
consuming what amount of power.
But how do you get to this?
There's a simple
ADB command, dumpsys
batterystats, that dumps out the
battery-relevant information.
The --charged is
just to make sure you
get the data since the last time
the device was fully charged.
That way you reduce
some of the noise,
and you get a nice clean
discharge cycle into this data.
You can also supply
the package name,
which would make sure that
the data is restricted
to your specific application.
Otherwise you'll get the
global stats as well.
So let's take a
look at what you get
when you type this command in.
One of the things you
get is the global stats.
This is actually really
interesting information.
It's giving you a macro
view over that discharge
cycle about what happened,
what consumed the power.
So some of the things that are
interesting here to us when
we look at these are the
partial wakelock time.
If that time is
really, really high,
then you know that
something was off.
Something was keeping the
processor awake way too long,
and that was probably the
culprit that you can go after.
You can also see
the total run time.
In addition to that,
you can see things
like the mobile radio
being on, the packets
that were received on a
mobile radio versus Wi-Fi,
and that can give you a sense
of what the network activity was
like during that
discharge cycle.
We have also added a brand new
thing to this battery stats
in L, something called the
milliseconds per packet.
This is actually
quite interesting.
What it's showing
is the total number
of packets sent by
a particular UID.
And a UID, again,
for your application,
is you can go look
that up in DDMS.
It's the same UID
that's used here.
It shows you the
number of packets
that your application sent
and the time that it took.
So you can see, for
example, the first example
here, UIDA is extremely
inefficient because it sent
only four packets but
it took over 12 seconds
to accomplish that.
Let's take a look at
another example here.
So UIDs B and C. So B, you can
see that it sent 3,600 packets
over 42 minutes, versus C sent
about the same, 4,000 packets,
but only over two minutes.
So there's a huge
difference there,
and it tells you
that one was far more
efficient in transmitting that
information than the other.
Now, this could be for
completely legitimate reasons,
or it could be an area
that you can investigate
to figure out what was going on.
Next, we have
aggregated stats by UID.
Again, that same UID I mentioned
for your application package.
Here you can see data that is
specific to your application--
similar things like
mobile time used.
An interesting thing here is
the processor wakelock usage.
So if you recall, what happens
when we talked about the CPU
being awake?
When you wake up
the CPU, there's
time spent to
perform the actions
that your application
wants to perform,
but then that also enables
other applications to wake
up and perform other actions.
So those actions that is
allowing other applications
to do things while
you're holding that
wakelock-- that is now being
blamed to your application
by 50%.
So 50% of that
extra time is being
blamed to your application.
Then finally, there
is Battery History.
This is really powerful.
This is showing me every
single battery-related event
that happened over
that discharge cycle.
You can find this
in a bug report.
Just look for the DUMP OF
SERVICE batterystats header,
and you can find
this information.
It's actually at the top
of the Battery Stats.
And here you can see things like
when the mobile radio was up,
when wakelocks were being
held, or different wake reasons
for the wakelocks.
And from this, you can
determine unusual patterns
of power consumption
or system activity.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: I don't know,
Meghan, just looking at this--
I'm sure there's a lot
of really rich data--
but there's way too many
symbols and complicated numbers
and names.
If there was some
way to make this
more transparent to the user, I
think it'd be much more useful.
MEGHAN DESAI: You think so?
All right, Matthew,
just for you,
we built a two-clock
battery historian.
So like Matthew, I like
visualizations as well.
And when I looked
at this bug report,
it was actually crazy
amounts of information.
I tried to put the
whole thing into here,
but it was just
way, way too long.
And so to be able to consume
all that information nicely,
you need a nice
visualization, and that's
why we built Battery Historian.
What it takes is it
takes those battery stats
and spits out some
nice visualization.
It's a Python script that
builds an HTML visualization.
So enough talking about
this magical tool.
Let's see what this produced.
So Matthew was kind enough to
donate one of his bug reports
to analyze here.
So let's look at some
activity on his phone.
This is showing just the first
few hours of that discharge
cycle, and you can see a
lot of different roads here.
So we're going to
zoom into this,
but each of these
rectangles are representing
when that activity was
reported, for example.
So let's actually
take a closer look.
We're going to zoom into that
part of the-- let's do this.
All right.
So the first row there
is the battery level.
This is when the battery
level was reported,
and the system logs that.
So you can see, for
example, you hover
over one of these
rectangles, and you
can see that the battery
level reported was down to 93%
at that point.
Again, this is since
the last time the device
was fully charged, so you're
expecting a discharge curve
there.
Let's take a look
at this next row.
Top.
Top means, what was the
application running at the top?
What was the user actually
using at that time
that's reported here?
And so let's see
what Matthew was
doing in those big
red rectangles.
So that second rectangle--
looks like Matthew
was using WhatsApp.
That's cool, Matthew.
Communicating on WhatsApp.
You got friends.
That's cool.
Let's look at what
else he was doing.
Ah, this other big rectangle
that you see there-- he
was using the dialer
app, so maybe he
was making a phone call.
We'll find out.
Let's see what happens.
All right.
We look at some of
these other lines.
That big green line--
Wi-Fi was running,
so he was on Wi-Fi
the whole time.
That's pretty cool.
Next, let's look at
this screen line.
What's happening here?
It's interesting.
I can see already that the first
two rectangles are correlated
with the first two red
rectangles up on the top,
and it looks like the screen was
on when he was using WhatsApp.
That makes sense.
Let's see what else is here.
Ah, phone and call.
All right.
It looks like he
was making a call.
We were right that when
the dialer was up top,
he was actually in a phone call.
So look at how easy
that was for me
to take that complicated
battery stats history report
and quickly identify the
patterns of behavior and usage
there.
Now let's dig deeper
into actually identifying
some of the problem areas
that we're talking about.
So this other part of the report
we can now zoom into-- you
can see things like
wakelocks being reported,
when the system was running,
things when mobile radio was
on and off, and the
reasons for the wakelocks.
And again, as I
mentioned, hovering over
these rectangles can
give you more insight
into what that entry
is in the logs.
So let's take a look
at another bug report.
Now, we decided to
do a simulation.
We looked at data--
the actual usage data
from a whole bunch of
our testers at Google.
And based on the
data from there,
we created 50
simulated applications,
and we wanted to
see what happens,
and we collected
this bug report.
So let's see what's
going on here.
I'm going to zoom in
again in that bottom part.
It looks like there's
some activity there.
Holy crap.
All right.
So there's a lot of
rectangles there.
Looks like there's
a lot happening.
All these applications
are hyperactive.
Hey, Matthew, do you think
the paradigms of "lazy first"
could be applied here?
Maybe these things
are legitimate,
but maybe we could apply
those paradigms here.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Yes.
So, Meghan, this looks
like a prime candidate
for the types of
defer and coalescing
that we were talking
about earlier.
I mean, you see all
these striations,
which basically means that the
phone is waking up, grabbing
a wakelock, doing some
really small amounts of work,
and going back to sleep.
This is bad because your paying
that overhead of loading up
the application process
up every single time
you see one of these spikes.
And the same things happen
with the mobile radio.
It's important to remember
here that, again, you
have that really expensive
long tail of not quite idle,
not quite active states.
And we're paying that
penalty every single time
one of these little blocks ends.
Because the mobile radio is
coming up, you're using it,
and it's going right back down.
So as Meghan said,
we've got this data
from a bunch of
Google employees.
So we have these
50 applications,
and we simulated this traffic by
using the Alarm Manager to just
naively wake up the application
and send some [INAUDIBLE]
to know it's network traffic,
and then assume that it's
going to finish its work,
and go back to sleep.
So we decided to make these
applications more lazy
by adding a deferral
between 0 and 30 seconds.
And we just randomly chose
a number between 0 and 30
for each of these network calls,
for each of these applications.
So I'm not saying
that it's 30 seconds.
I'm saying that,
on average, it's
probably going to be about
15 seconds, because this
was a uniform
random distribution.
And we're going to get as many
deferrals as 0 as we do 30.
So 0 seconds of deferral being
the active case, where it just
doesn't try to
wait around at all.
And let's see what we got.
So immediately, even from
a layman's perspective,
the bottom table
is much cleaner.
We don't have nearly
as many wakeups,
which indicate that when
the phone does wake up,
you see the mobile
network is active.
So work is being
done, and then it
goes back to sleep
at the end of that.
Look at the shape of this mobile
video traffic at the bottom.
It's much more compact.
There are much fewer
of these boxes.
So we're paying much less
of this overhead penalty
per mobile video
active transition.
So I think this
looks pretty good.
MEGHAN DESAI: Matthew,
that is amazing.
This is amazing.
So you were able to use the
JobScheduler APIs to coalesce
a lot of this
activity, and we're
paying less of that
overhead penalty
repeatedly that we
talked about earlier.
So these are just beautiful
battery historian images.
But what was the actual
impact on battery life like?
MATTHEW WILLIAMS:
Yeah, you're right.
I mean, it's one thing
to show a nice picture
but the value that we're
trying to quantify here
is battery life.
And so this simulation
was run over two days,
both for the active
Alarm Manager
case and the lazy
JobScheduler case.
And in the former debug,
we started at 100%,
and it dropped down to about
55% battery life after two days.
And lastly, the JobScheduler
the drop was from 100%
to about 70%.
So that's a really
remarkable difference,
and I'm not making a
statement that we're
going to see this improvement
in battery life across the board
as soon as everybody jumps
onboard one of these APIs.
But it does give kind
of a ballpark estimate
of the types of
improvements we can make.
MEGHAN DESAI: Yeah, but that's
still really, really cool
that you were able to get
a 15% to 20% increase.
Granted, this is a
simulated use case,
but that means that there's
some real-world battery
impact you could have for users.
That's really cool.
Now, Matthew, if I understood
the simulation correctly,
though, you weren't
optimizing just the one app.
You had to optimize
all 50 of the apps.
Is that right?
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Yeah.
So essentially what this
simulation comes like is that,
I'm some [INAUDIBLE].
I jumped into a device, and
I decided to artificially
make each network request lazy.
And that just isn't the case.
This is something that
will affect everybody.
This is something we're
thinking about in the framework.
This is something that we're
thinking about in Google Play
services.
And this is also
the kind of thing
that affects all of you
guys, the developers.
But the issue with it
being a collective problem
is that, when we start making
steps in the right direction,
we can reap the
collective rewards.
MEGHAN DESAI: That's very
eloquently put, Matthew.
Thank you.
He's exactly right.
This is something
that we all have
to embrace and help address.
And if I were to sum
up this whole talk,
we'd just tell you
about procrastinating.
We want you to build apps
that procrastinate, that
are lazy first.
You can use the
JobScheduler APIs
to help do that in
an efficient way
and allow the platform to
optimize how it helps utilize
the underlying system resources
in a power-efficient manner.
And then finally,
Battery Historian
is a tool that can
help you digest
large amounts of
battery-related statistics
and see them visually
in a nice timeline.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Yeah, man.
That Battery Historian too was
excellent, but how do people
actually use it?
Because it's one
thing to say a tool
exists and another thing to put
it in the hands of developers.
MEGHAN DESAI: That's
actually a really good point.
Battery Historian
is a tool that we
are open-sourcing
for all of you guys.
As I mentioned, it's
a Python script.
You can find it at
that GitHub URL today.
Keeping in mind, though, it will
work with battery statistics
from the L Preview Build, which
will be available tomorrow.
So once you start
running that Build,
you can gather the
battery stats and start
using Battery Historian
to visualize those stats.
Also, if you have any
questions about what we just
talked about-- Project Volta,
JobScheduler APIs, or Battery
Historian-- we have office
hours for Project Volta
from 3:00 to 4:00 PM
today and tomorrow
at the Android Sandbox booth.
It's just right outside.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Yeah.
So we went over the
JobScheduler in some detail,
and there's also an I/O
Bytes video up on YouTube
if you want to dig some
more into this stuff.
But if you're interested in just
jumping straight into the code,
we have a sample app up, which
will let you set up these jobs.
It gives you a very simple
UI to specify the constraints
that you're
interested in and get
the callback from the system.
So that's up on GitHub.
It's Google Samples,
Android JobScheduler.
MEGHAN DESAI: And
we started this talk
by saying that we're
passionate about battery life.
This is not just something
that we're passionate
about in the Android
framework but across Google.
And so I'd encourage
you to check out
some of the other sessions, like
the "Achieving More With Mobile
Cloud," where they might
talk about some of the APIs
that they're
introducing and building
to help make things
more power efficient
and make it easier for you
guys to make your applications
more power efficient as well.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Yeah,
Meghan, thanks a lot, man.
I thoroughly enjoyed that talk.
I thought you were
eloquent and well-spoken.
MEGHAN DESAI: Thank you, Matt.
Likewise, likewise.
And thank you all for
attending the session.
We hope you enjoyed it as
much as Matthew and I did.
Now go out there and try
out these APIs and Battery
Historian and let us
know what you think.
MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Yeah, thanks.
MEGHAN DESAI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]